>> Now, in order to update the cx and cy offsets for trimmed sprites, we have to
do a couple of interesting things. First off, you need to understand that
[unknown] will only do a smart trim from the edges to the center. So, for
instance, if you end up in a situation where you got a nice box and pixels in
the top left quadrant, it won't actually trim that sprite because it can't
shrink it to the center. Because of this, we don't actually need any of the
information from the frame in order to create the new cx and cy values. Instead,
all we have to do is figure out the half dimensions for the sprite and create an
inverse of that, which represents our offset. Now, we store the cx and cy here,
which means if the sprite is or is not trimmed, it doesn't really matter in the
drawing function that uses these values later.